припис між рядовим актом про
здачу приймання технічна допомога
завершена tab 2 сторони фітнесу наш
україну та китайську народну республіку
новому в результаті дружно 2 краєм для
віч вади гозіас вигляд і стала
гуманітарного допомагає КНР або леді
комп'ютерна техніка
між керівниками двох держав
була досягнута домовленість про те, що
китайська народна республіка надає
допомога Україні для розвитку гуманітарної
сфери
після цього уряд України
провело кілька внутрішніх процедур та
було ухвалено рішення кабінету міністрів
україни що ця допомога буде
надана вона буде направлена ​​на
розвиток середньої освіти нагару та
маму наварити близько двох із половиною
тисяч українських шишкіна примали
комп'ютерним класом я пасти падар він до
старий на техніку до України доставив і
3 гігантськими такі два поверхи повісимо
висотою шкірок біля церкви 2012 року
так українській школі ріо при молодь та
23 тисячі китайських комп'ютерів на суму
близько 12 мільйонів доларів США не погано
разу продав і до управління свити всіх
областей та автономні республіки крим
комп'ютери штангу над опротестували до
початку початкову руку теж пішов vrs на
школа реджі
до розступалася обновками одягу
пасеровану правдиву інформацію
протягнути комп'ютери не бутони продати
не для нігтями
чіткої поблизу простого не і слідкуй за це
представлені в двох краєм втомився each на
спеціалізовану школу перспектива
новий 194 деякі журналісти не
розібравшись намагалися говорити про те, що
техніка не підходить і є проблеми ми
одразу пан їм послом разом поїхали
у звичайну школу не в центрі міста не
сама
і подивилися грабують 8 його народилася
кожен зробив індивідуальну програму
англійською українською та деякі
навіть іноді китайською китайською мовою
мені дуже сподобалися побачити посмішку на
вагах
у юних школярів друзів я радий що
китайська комп'ютерна техніка за графом
українським школярам спершу біднота ми
ж світи нам і 2 краєм продовжується
розвивається практика обміну студентами
закладу чами та професором та тарик 200
українських дітей побували на китайських
курортах а сто наших студентів ранку мало
стипендій вид КНР цього року ми також
на чиї продовжимо таку практику як
унітарної допомоги якщо вона потрібна і будемо
почати працювати спільно, щоб громадяни
китаю та україни побачили обмацали
конкретні результати ось наші з вами
спільної роботи партнерство між вами
околицях і набираючи звернувши спів брати
ще до них проектів силу show dance
наприклад між рядами їх внесків